how to turn your idea into a business or
career so I got a great question from
one of my YouTube viewers la Draper 99
who wrote in to say hi Evan hope all is
well I have a question I work full-time
at a company but it's not doing
something I'm passionate about my
passion that gives me great joy is
encouraging others and talking to them
about their issues how can I turn this
into a business end or career this is a
great question and I really feel for you
it sucks to wake up every day and go to
a job that you hate and this is what 80%
of North America does they wake up and
they go to a job that they're not
passionate about that they hate doing so
that they can come home leave work at
five o'clock and they're living for the
evenings and weekends for me that's not
a way to live and I get that it's hard
it's hard leaving that stability but
it's something that if you're not
passionate about it I don't get how
people can live and not do things that
they're passionate about anyway so
congratulations on having the courage
here to want to step outside do
something a little different that might
be scary that might be risky because
you're passionate about it it's
important how do you follow this up so
my advice for you is one get specific
you need to know who you're helping you
want to help people with their issues
everybody has issues right everybody
there's nobody in the world who doesn't
have issues so who do you want to help
write what kinds of people do you want
to help get specific and define it do
you want to help kids do you want to
help people who who are going through
marital problems do you want to help
entrepreneurs starting up you want to
help people who are on a charitable
mission like who do you want to help get
specific I may be already know this
maybe you know and that helps but it's
not being communicated right you didn't
tell me or maybe you don't know I need
to get some clarity so figure that out
you have to figure out be specific who
do you want to help second thing is do
you want to be an entrepreneur or you
want to just have a career and there's
nothing wrong with having a career that
fulfills you that makes you happy that
gives you your passion you don't have to
be an entrepreneur as much as I love
entrepreneurs and helping people become
their own business owner it doesn't have
to be that way you know if you don't
have the
set to be an entrepreneur don't be an
entrepreneur I have the zuga mindset
test that helps people figure out if
they're meant to be an entrepreneur now
if you have that right mindset and if
it's not for you that's great like it's
good to know that you can get whatever
fulfillment you have potentially from a
career if you're not meant to be an
entrepreneur so you think about helping
people so you know do you want to be a
guidance counselor do you want to be a
marriage counselor do you want to be a
psychologist right there's tons of
opportunities there are tons of
traditional paths that you can take
without having a launch your own company
that might make you feel passionate so
you got to figure out do you want a
career you want to fit into the
structure in the system or do you want
to launch your own company there's two
different paths and the third thing is
get started okay you don't need to go
quit your job and have you know no
income coming in and and you know burn
the boats and go and try this new thing
start part-time start small you know if
you don't know who you want to help just
start either volunteering get a
part-time job
help people on the side but explore do
something every week that you're
spending some time to explore yourself
explore your passion and see who you
really love helping out it may be
volunteering part-time at a school and
being a part-time guidance counselor or
helping some people probably know
volunteering again or taking a part-time
job at a psychology you know with a with
a psychologist who's helping people work
through their issues right starts
because you're learning and there's
gonna be some opportunities that you go
to and you'll be you know like you know
that's great but it's not really for me
and there'll be one that you go to and
just think wow I want to do this I want
to do this more and and that's when you
know that you found your passion right
that's you know you want to be like that
person you want to be in this industry
and it could be as a job or it could be
starting your own company but when you
experience it you get that feeling that
makes you come alive you know you've got
to keep doing this you look at famous
entrepreneurs you look at how they got
started you look at why they got started
because they got that hot
right they love what they do it's not
just about making money they truly
deeply passionately love what they do so
you've got to find that you got to find
what it is that gets you so excited and
it comes from trying so don't that this
is a great start being frustrated with
your current work having a general sense
of where you want to go that's a great
start the difference so here is you need
to act and act part-time small-scale but
consistently something every single week
that you are doing to explore this
passion of yours until you find the
thing that makes you come alive and say
I need to go do this when you find that
then you know you're on the right path
believe for those of you watching I'd
love to hear what you have to think let
me know how you've broken out of the
nine-to-five job or how you found your
passion leave it in the comments below
I'd love to hear your story because it
will help inspire the people as well
give it a thumbs up if you liked this
video it makes you want to do more for
you and click on my face to subscribe to
the channel see more videos like this
thank you so much let's see you soon